[Musique]
on commence par quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la musique du peuple
ça rassemble les gens
[Musique]
vous êtes vraiment une super star
je suis pas une super star
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est la guerre
et on peut pas séparer la musique et le
message
c'est quoi le message
la paix
ils sont tentés de vous tuer vous et
votre femme et maintenant vous décidez
de retourner en Jamaïque participer à un
concert pour la paix
vous n'avez pas peur de mourir
[Musique]
ma vie n'a pas d'importance pour moi
moi je vis pour les autres
vous croyez vraiment que ce monde va
s'en sortir
il y a pas d'autre ici
c'est la source de ta force
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un seul amour un seul cœur un seul
destin
[Musique]